the health officials say given the
nature of this primary given kind of the
way you go in and do one one opal most
of the time for most counties that under
that can be done safely okay
governor Rhonda Santa's insisting that
it's safe for Florida voters to head to
the polls tomorrow despite more than 150
confirmed cases of coronavirus in
Florida Biden and Sanders who have both
shifted their campaigns toward virtual
events will also square off in Arizona
Illinois and now Ohio as well despite
the governor Mike DeWine who we spoke
with earlier pressing to delay it
Florida senator Rick Scott joins me now
he has been self-quarantine for days
after he has come in contact with
brazil's president whose aid tested
positive for coronavirus senator good to
see you tonight thank you for being with
us and first of all how are you doing
and how much longer will you be self
quarantined this is my 8th day I've
never taken my temperature as much as
I've taken in the last few days I see
that 97.5 pretty consistently so I don't
have a fever and that's the most that's
the first thing that happens so it's not
the most fun thing to do I like my
family and I like the people I work with
so I'd like to be out of the house but
I'm calling on mayors I'm calling on
hospital system doctors I'm calling
sheriff's police departments just to
make sure they have all the resources
they need yeah you know just a personal
question first you know we're just at
the very beginning of this and we've
been asked now to stay put like you have
for 15 days you know in a very hardcore
way in order to kind of give us a little
bit of a breather here how do you think
Americans are gonna do with this over
the long term oh I think Americans will
show up look we've got it we've got to
do some extreme things here because
you're right yeah you and you were just
talking about we're gonna need to go to
the path of South Korea or they're gonna
go to the path of Italy and I think
we're gonna go the path of South Korea
because we our goal we have to get this
testing up this week and we need to be
able to do rapid tests we've got to
secure borders I think that's gonna
happen our governors have got to figure
out how they can make sure we get social
distancing it's way better in the
federal guard
we got we've got to take care of our
healthcare workers so we've got to have
this protective gear we've got to figure
this out how do we get more of it how do
we protect it and gosh why are we why
was anybody Proust got price gouging our
Attorney General's have to show up and
stop that yeah how do you feel Florida
is doing in terms of equipment that's
needed and swabs and protective gear and
all of that I think a lot of Americans
are surprised that we you know that some
places don't have what they need well it
depends on where you are and we but
health care is a local locally delivered
system so our local health care systems
with our local County Health
Department's with our physician groups
they all have to get together and figure
out what can they produce that maybe
they don't have are theirs is your
equipment that we can put to work that's
been used for something else so we've
got it we've got to be very very
creative and at every level local state
and federal we've got a waive
regulations to take care of our those
regulations might make sense at a
different time we're in a crisis and we
all have to do this together and it's
your personal responsibility to figure
this out the federal government cannot
solve every problem we've got to have
our families or churches our mayor's or
communities we all have to get together
on this and solve this problem this is a
local problem right now it's a local
health care delivery system I hear you
cook very quickly I so do you think it
was the right decision to go ahead and
hold the primary tomorrow you feel safe
about that well you can you know Martha
Florida you can vote early and you can
vote by absentee and we have locally
elected supervisor election so if you
have a concern call your supervisor
election and say how are you keeping me
safe okay senator Scott thank you great
to talk to you tonight thank you for
being here